this episode is brought to you by
today's sponsor i'm juno alex i just had
the best idea ever what if we could have
something that could function as both a
checking account and a crypto platform
at the same time imagine how much easier
that would make everything jack that
already exists it's called on juno on
juno is a banking platform where you can
seamlessly manage your cash and crypto
holdings all in one place on juno offers
six percent yearly savings by making
digital dollars like usdc a stable coin
pegged to the us dollar with a market
cap of nearly 50 billion dollars work
for you without any lock-ups or fees or
annoying caps on your earnings they even
offer a medal yeah you heard me metal
debit card that gives you 10 cashback on
five brands of your choice when you sign
up with direct deposit of 250 and above
and if you're still not quite sure about
usdc and you're scared of the risks
associated with it that's totally fine
because their cash balances are fdic
insured and you can earn 1.2 percent
which is a lot higher than even your
average bank account and you also have
free atm access at over 80 000 locations
like walgreens 711 cvs and more on juno
also has no minimum balance requirements
no monthly fees and also no overdraft
fees too so check it out guys we've left
a link down below in description where
you can learn more about on juno we
really appreciate it again guys check it
out link in the description to learn
more about on juno thanks so much on
juno and back to the podcast hey
everybody my name is adam22 welcome back
to the iced coffee hour and to this date
we have made
three hundred thousand dollars
great guess two hundred thousand one
hundred and fifty three dollars and
eighty cents pretty close and what an
intro it's almost like you do this for a
living yeah i got a syrupy voice i'm
like a phone sex operator
you really do you really do appreciate
that cut it out guys
anyway save it for after the podcast
okay thank you so much for coming all
the way out here it's an honor man i
watch you guys podcast i'm a big fan
i've learned a lot
so i appreciate it it's crazy for me
because i have watched your podcast for
quite some time you've had so many
people on there and like from for me to
like have you here it's just it's crazy
wow i appreciate that yeah it really is
we had no idea that you watched our
stuff and it's always crazy to learn who
does well i was watching the youtube
uploads for a while before i got turned
on to the podcast which is kind of weird
that like you could exist in one part of
youtube interacting with the creator and
not really get exposed to their other
thing but the algorithm started pushing
some random episode on me and then i
just started going back through and
learning a bunch so yeah
thanks to the algorithm guys
if you want to help that algorithm all
you got to do subscribe hit the like
button and comment anything down below
because it does make a difference i've
noticed it does so well thank you for
coming on um where did you get your
start because you've interviewed such
incredible people you've grown this pot
your podcast to just incredible numbers
right well so 2006 i uh you know i've
been running bmx bikes since i was like
12 years old was was super into that my
whole life uh and then i moved to new
york city in 2003 when i was 19 and
pretty pretty i started playing online
poker for a couple years and then in
2006 at age 22 i was spending so much
time online playing poker that i started
you know really poking around in the
blogosphere at the time and my other
main interest at that time was hip-hop
so i started to see all these rap blogs
and everything and they're really
starting to take hold 2005 2006 and i
started to notice like a change in my
behavior where all of a sudden i wasn't
buying a magazine at the store every
month about rap music i was just reading
this blog every day
and so you know a little part of me was
like well maybe i could have a rap blog
and then it was i was too insecure about
that at the time i was like i don't
really feel like i have enough
specialized knowledge about that but
then it clicked like i know almost
everything about bmx bikes so i started
that website within like a year or so it
was like hugely popular i felt like i
was pretty much like a household name in
my
niche and so i just kind of kept
grinding that from like 2006 to maybe
2012. i moved to la in 2010 and um 2011
2012-ish is when i really realized like
oh
this blog is becoming less relevant and
social media is becoming way more
important so i started to really kind of
just dedicate like big chunks of my time
to just figuring out
what my direction was going to be in
that regard and you know at some point i
got turned on the joe rogan experience
and started to you know find out about
all the rap podcasts of the time like uh
the the combat jack show and the joe
budden podcast and stuff and started to
click in my head like i know
i know all these bmx riders maybe i can
get my start
interviewing bmx company owners and and
pro riders and stuff like that and then
like very very quickly i interviewed one
underground rapper and it did very very
significant numbers
you know in the bmx world it's very easy
to just be kind of like stuck in that
niche you know and never really peak
outside of it there's a lot of things
that are like that i'm in the poker and
poker is kind of very very similar where
everybody who plays poker seems to know
about all the same stuff and then
everybody outside of it seems completely
clueless to everything but as soon as i
did that one piece of content with a
rapper i just kind of realized like oh
i'm around a lot of people that are not
really being heard right now but their
music videos might get a couple million
views if i interview those guys it'll
probably do pretty good
i started to do that i started
interviewing you know youtubers and
comedians and porn stars and just really
felt like
if i kept going and if i kept grinding
it out and just really trying to get
better and and not just that but also
kind of climbing this like social ladder
that previously i felt like i had no
access to because in the bmx world again
nobody cares like nothing you could do
in that world is gonna
really make anybody pay attention to you
you know and then all of a sudden i have
my foot in the door and i'm just kind of
doing everything i can to get all these
different interviews done and that's
basically been like the last six years
of my life or so that i've just been
trying to
make it work so when you were doing
poker when you said you were what like
22 or so yeah did you find that like
profitable were you really good at poker
so that was the very very early days of
online poker where oh yeah everything
was illegal it was being advertised on
tv non-stop everybody was horrible in
comparison to now everybody is fairly
good at poker so it's a lot harder to
make a living now but yeah i definitely
had a couple of 100 000 plus years
playing online poker that that was my
main form of sustenance before the blog
kind of kicked off but then as soon as
the blog kicked off
i started to be honest with myself and i
was like i don't feel like i'm gifted at
poker and i don't feel like uh this is
for me like i just i just kind of knew
like i want to dedicate all my time to
trying to make this uh blog pop off and
how do you scale a blog and also how did
you monetize the blog so you know this
is 2006 it's like very very early days
of making money through being like an
influencer or having a platform i
remember somebody saying to me like
you know you need to start running ads
and i said nobody's making money off ads
unless you're in google or something you
know which is so crazy now because even
a tiny youtuber is thinking about you
know maybe i can pay my rent off making
videos or whatever and uh at that time
it was basically just me trying to
convince all these different bmx
companies to to give me like 200 300
bucks a month and i was able to kind of
cobble that together until it started to
look like some kind of legitimate income
but then also on top of that you know i
was running sort of like programmed ads
on the side from google or whatever and
actually at times i had really big
success with that because like i said i
started in 2006 at some point in 2007 i
had like a company get in touch with me
who were like oh we're going to run ads
on the side of your website and they pay
very very well i said okay first month i
made 10 grand from just those ads and
then the [ __ ] financial crash hit the
next month
and all these banks and all these
advertisers just it plummeted it turned
into like a thousand bucks a month
overnight so that was like one of many
moments where it seemed like things were
gonna work out a little better how are
you how are you like paying for housing
food and stuff like that when you went
from like 10 000 a month down to a grand
let's just say were you making money
elsewhere i didn't stop playing poker
until i was making like three grand a
month which to me at that time that was
what i felt like i needed to get by
living in new york city which you know
my rent i think i was splitting a
thousand dollar a month apartment with
my girlfriend at the time so that was
reasonable and i mean i felt rich making
five grand a month you know i felt like
i was killing it like because i couldn't
you know i was doing what i really
really wanted to do and when i look at
that at that time
i had a very big opportunity to sort of
pivot and maybe not just do the bmx
thing maybe like start doing some other
niches and stuff like that but you know
i was so young and my my mind state was
just 100 like i love riding bikes i love
making bike videos i just want to be out
in the city doing this [ __ ] and so it
kind of took me a while before i sort of
realized that i didn't have to limit
myself to doing content about one thing
so you were basically just acting as
like a marketing agency for a bunch of
different bmx companies and then
promoting their products or whatever to
the people that went and visited your
blog but you also ran ads for those
other companies as well yeah yeah we
were running ads on the side but then
also there was some degree where like
you know if they're advertising you know
i figured that out at one point like oh
if they advertise with us we're gonna
link to their website in the post about
their video and otherwise we're just
gonna run their video and you know not
really give them any extra promotion or
anything like that but uh yeah and when
i look back at it like the real reason
why the bmx blog became such a big deal
so quickly because i'm in new york city
i'm 22 years old i have no connection to
the bmx industry which is pretty much at
that time 100 located in southern
california and i was talking [ __ ] about
everything and anything you know my
perez hilton a bmx right but but not in
a way of like trying to be an [ __ ] i
just was being completely honest about
everything and i pretty much immediately
earned the ire of all of the bmx media
people because i was really [ __ ] up
their business and i'm like destroying
these million dollar media companies in
bmx because all of a sudden these
magazines are like
not anywhere near as relevant as they
were before and then in comparison i'm
making this tiny amount of money in
comparison but like i really look back
at that and i see that
and i'm like wow that was pretty
incredible i was able to have that
effect on that industry but then at the
same time
um
what what
[ __ ] it up was that i really wanted to
make more money so i started to tone
down my editorial voice and stop talking
so much
and when i look back at that i really
kind of feel guilty about that because i
would have much rather kept that
platform pure and
mean and funny and just you know it's
like i i i look back now that i've
actually kind of gotten to the money and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i made a lot of
decisions that weren't really me
throughout my life because i wanted to
you know be financially stable so that's
one thing i kind of look back on and i'm
like i never want to do that to no
jumper i never want to like really just
kind of limit myself editorially just to
make somebody happy you know yeah is
there is there any blog that you wrote
that sticks out is like most impactful
or something like that or something that
really kind of threw the industry in a
spiral yeah i would just do all these
blogs where i would just pick one thing
that was normal and i would just tear it
apart and explain why it sucked and why
you should never do it again and there's
like what's an example so there's a bike
trick or like a there's a thing and this
sounds terrible and racist these days
but we would call it an indian it's
basically like if you do a 180 and then
instead of turning around and completing
the rotation you would like 180 and then
spin back the wrong way
oh yeah
you take it back yeah
so it's an indian giver this is like
2006 this is what we call that it seems
kind of weird i heard a lot of people in
bmx don't call it that anymore but i
remember just writing an article of just
explaining of how stupid the idea is of
doing a 180 and then turning back again
like not completing the rotation like
this is so obvious to me so i write this
blog i get so much [ __ ] for it where
people just claiming that this is
freestyle and it's supposed to be about
having fun and you're an athlete you're
trying to take the fun out of bmx i
swear to god i almost never saw anybody
do one again after that but first we
gotta thank our sponsor ftxus now's a
great time to buy crypto but finding a
reputable trustworthy exchange isn't
always easy but it is easyjack because
we have ftx down below in the
description we both use the ftx app to
trade crypto and we just love how easy
it is to use and how great it looks yeah
i really like how you could set up
automatic recurring buys that you could
dollar cost average into the markets on
a regular basis and that's what i've
been doing and also another thing to
consider is a lot of other exchanges
they charge hefty fees on like every
crypto transaction which is
yeah i hate ia fees but their fees are
up to 85 lower than the top competitors
and they're one of the largest u.s
regulated cryptocurrency exchanges in
terms of daily users and trading volume
and by the way guys graham doesn't know
this yet i've kept it a secret from him
because it's just that exciting but ftx
is planning on incorporating stocks at
some point in the future so it's going
to be an all-in-one inclusive platform
where you can trade crypto and nfts with
no fees and also stocks there too it's
going to be amazing you guys should
definitely check it out so if you guys
want to support the podcast and check it
out ftx has been amazing to us they're a
huge sponsor of the podcast we really
appreciate them go check out that link
down below in the description and trade
crypto and nfts with no fees today again
the link is down below in the
description and you can get all the way
up to a hundred dollars with a free
crypto when you sign up using our link
enjoy and now let's get back to the
podcast the thing that's funny to me is
that you were hating on that trick where
it's like you jump back and you jump
forward but i feel like
like like if you're just riding a bmx
shouldn't you just like do what you want
and do maybe what looks cool
like i sure logistically it doesn't make
sense to like to do 180 just to do it
right back if i showed you it on camera
right now you would be like oh my god
they're so ugly
not even the way you think about bike
riding you would see it and it's just
like offensive the way it looks because
it doesn't look right and at the time
people would do it really really bad and
you know i just had an opinion and to me
that's like
i can't tell you you know a fashion
blogger can say like oh like this brand
of pants is terrible and a rap
you know now this is so normal that a
rap blogger is going to say or a vlogger
or whatever is going to say this album
is trash
this guy's girlfriend is
not a good person that makes that's not
how i was going to end that sentence
when i started it but you know like just
all these like it's okay to have an
opinion now yeah but there are like like
i i watch a lot of skateboarding sort of
meta commentary content and i've seen
them kind of like going through this
where there's certain youtubers who kind
of have a presence now who they just
talk [ __ ] about skateboarding and they
get so much [ __ ] it's not an industry
that's really like kind to people being
really fiercely critical of it which
doesn't happen in a lot of other niches
like in hip-hop you can just say
whatever you want but isn't that a part
of it though isn't it assumed that
you're going to kind of trash talk each
other and that's just
a part of growing yeah i think it should
be more
you know more accepted if anything like
i was watching a uh
one of these skateboard guys that i
watched this dude gifted hater who just
talks about skateboarding stuff and he
he showed this skateboarding contest
that had been streamed online and he's
playing clips from the commentary that
they were doing and he's pointing out
how stupid and how fake the things that
the commentators saying are and he's
like why don't the announcers of this
contest talk to us like they assume that
we have some degree of intelligence
and i was like that is a great [ __ ]
point i've never heard anybody make that
point like on camera before in this way
but somehow like these action sports are
very very resistant to any sort of like
introspection how many viewers did you
have to this vlog the blog back then
it's hard for me to say blog because i
just want to say vlog it's hard to
accumulate to even remember yeah like i
have no clue in retrospect any number i
would say would be probably just a lie
but it was you know probably it was by
far bigger than any other bmx website at
that time so yeah what happened to it
could you ever sell it i didn't it
like once no jumper started to really
pop off
i kind of just put it on autopilot had a
couple of bloggers updating it and stuff
and and it just
sort of faded into irrelevance and then
at some point just kind of took it down
and and i do look back at it and i wish
that i had been able to continue to
scale my business and start doing this
other side of the content and like you
know be able to hire people who would be
good on camera to do that and i'm still
kind like i still have conversations
with some people on my team of like
maybe we could bring it back because now
we're making a lot more money on
facebook i'm like if we could just make
youtube content of bmx writing and then
also make money off it on facebook maybe
we'd have enough money to have two or
three people on staff to actually be
able to keep this brand going even if
it's not some big profit center for us
so i'm still kind of kicking it around
to be honest got it now on no jumper how
did you start 2014 we had a bike shop
downtown los angeles like basically on
the edge of skid row which is pretty
much the gnarliest place that you could
go in l.a it's like non-stop homeless
people and drug abuse and that was the
only place where we could really afford
a store at that time so we start the
store we've got you know some desks in
back where we were just sitting working
every day
and i uh i remember one day i just sat
down and i watched like five videos in a
row of like what equipment do i need to
start a podcast and eventually came to
some conclusions started ordering
everything i remember i just found a guy
on craigslist that said he was an audio
engineer and i'm like i'm gonna pay you
30 bucks an hour to stand in this room
and listen to this stuff and make sure
that it sounds okay and pretty quickly i
got it to the point where uh
where it just didn't even need anything
so i was going there doing interviews
with the rappers in the middle of the
night i'm showing up at 11 p.m i'm
taking my phone putting it on a bike
stand not even like a like a thing that
was meant to hold a phone and just
recording and a couple times i forgot to
put it on airplane mode and um like i
remember the ugly god podcast that i did
in 2016 like halfway through there's
just no video because it just turned off
traumatic but yeah over the years just
kind of started trying to get my setup
more and more consistent who's the
rapper he had first on that would like
kind of took it off
there was this dude xavier wolf he was
the first one who was like
he had a wave going at the time like
2016 where he was popular in like the
sort of downtown l.a like hipster type
world and uh yeah they're just kind of i
did one really good interview with him
and then that just kind of opened the
door where like a lot of other cool
rappers wanted to tap in and then the
one that really went crazy was i
interviewed xxx tentacion who was really
small at the time
uh he had one song with a million views
but i was getting all these comments but
people were fascinated by him and they
sent me links to videos of him fighting
people on the street outside of like
bars in downtown miami or something like
that there was a clip of him stabbing
somebody and i was just fascinated by
him so i did the interview with him
didn't really think that much of it it
was an hour it was a very very good
interview but it wasn't like i had no
idea his career was going to do that and
then he just absolutely exploded after
that and the interview might have had a
couple million views already by the time
he passed and then when i look back at
the graph of all of our views throughout
the history of our youtube channel the
day he died was the day that we got the
most views and you know over and over
and over doing this kind of content has
sort of shown me the value of content
and like the fact that when he died that
piece of content just became that much
more valuable because all of a sudden
this is just like a historical document
for people to understand this kid that
there's not going to be anything new to
understand him by you know and he only
did a handful of interviews
and i mean that that like even before he
passed it really changed my life all of
a sudden i had everybody in the music
industry hitting me up like futures
managers tapping in with me rocky asap
rockies managers tapping in with me and
this is for me at the time where i had
no connections to anybody
in the music industry but i did one
interview that just got me on
everybody's radar instantly and when i
look back at it it's like i very much
could have maybe not have been as big of
a presence and have been maybe more of
like a mid-tier
podcaster if it wasn't for that because
that really just blew [ __ ] out of the
water as soon as i had him on and really
showed me the value of getting in with
people early and documenting their life
and just content in general it seems
almost like you become uh
almost you know you know like the late
night talk shows where people come on
and they they talk about themselves and
they're kind of interviewed except
much longer and more like a like a real
in-depth conversation in music which did
that were people doing this before you
really dove into it well i got to give
salute to the the og dj vlad because he
really like
created like the blueprint for what it
was to do content with rappers online
when i started i honestly wasn't
thinking about him because to me
he's always kind of cut it into shorter
clips which i also think was like a
really important innovation even though
he took an amazing amount of [ __ ] for it
at the time because he was actually
drawing attention to what people were
saying in these interviews but um i was
very very early on it and especially
with the underground rappers it just
wasn't people doing content about them
and one of my things
i learned early on was
even if it's not the biggest rapper even
if they don't have a number one song
whatever like these are really
interesting personalities and when it
comes to the internet
the fact that your music isn't that
popping really doesn't matter if you
have a really amazing personality and if
you're real and you know just people
want to hear from you yeah how do you
pick people just my gut you know just
who i look at the analytics or whatever
i look at how they're doing on their
platform and a lot of times that'll tell
you something but a lot of times
i'll watch a smaller youtuber interview
them or i'll just get tuned into their
instagram i take suggestions from people
all the time um just try to keep my mind
as open as possible i just had this girl
cece reacts on who's
she i think she only has 50 000
subscribers she's growing really fast
though and she's just this
a little bit older woman i think she
might be almost 40. she did a bunch of
prison time for credit cards scamming
and [ __ ] and her
she's just amazing on camera
and when i heard her i was just like i
don't care at all that she has 50 000
subscribers like she's she's amazing
like i just want to put her out there to
the world and i really just believe
that it'll
prove to be a good decision you know how
much time do you spend researching your
guests before you have them on
see sometimes it'll be
you know like if i were gonna have you
on tomorrow yeah
i don't even know if i have to do any
research because i already watched a lot
of your podcast maybe i want to like
read through a bio so that little things
like where you're from or whatever
doesn't escape me but for the most like
you know i kind of feel like i don't
have to do any research but a lot of
times with the rappers i want to see
their videos i want to
have a decent idea and i do hold myself
to a pretty high standard with that
sometimes because i really i want to do
an interview a lot of times that is for
your fans you know i want to bring
something new out of you that will
actually make them happy you know i
don't want to like i call them cover
band interviews when people just do an
interview that somebody else has already
done and just repeat all the same
questions and i just think it's like
shameful and i just hold myself to a
higher standard than that but
you know then sometimes i mean i
remember back in the day i'd interview
wyclef from the
and i mean i probably spent a whole
weekend like
listening to it
listening to his music all day at night
i'm watching documentaries i'm just
trying to learn because his career was
just so vast
that i just felt like i had to know as
much as possible but through doing so
much research i've gotten like really
fast and efficient at actually figuring
out the stuff that i need to know i'm
always terrified of doing too much
research because sometimes i'll know
something and then not ask it because i
know it already versus going in doing
nothing and then showing up then i asked
the questions that i feel like a viewer
might also ask who's not familiar yeah
we try to go into each podcast with one
of us knowing a decent amount about the
guest and the other person knowing
nothing so you get both the in-depth
questions and the surface level
questions because realistically you come
on our podcast our audience for the most
part they're not gonna be the same as
your audience they won't know who you
are so like graham's gonna need to ask
the questions let's just let's just say
theoretically if he's not well
researched that they're gonna be wanting
to know and then i'll ask the questions
if i am the researched one that you know
your your audience would want to know
yeah that makes sense i just really
always try to bring something different
to it as well like i just had this guy
larry lawton on my podcast who's like
america's biggest jewel thief of all
time
and he he went on dj vlad maybe a year
or two ago and told his all his whole
story and then when i sat down with him
he was kind of like reiterating
parts of his story and everything and i
just uh you know i felt like we had a
conversation that very much like kind of
went beyond the basis of what he did in
his life you know where you can talk
about your opinion on things and all
these different things i just feel like
that's kind of important to be able to
expand upon what other people have
already done like in my head i want to
be doing some i like to hold my
audience to the standard of
catching up you know and then i want
your audience to actually be interested
in the interview it doesn't always work
out that way but i really like to
have my repeat audience kind of need to
know what's going on a little bit not
not that they need to know because we'll
cover the things but i like to just try
to keep them informed how do you do that
because i'm always trying to figure out
like i love joe rogan and how he asks
questions and it's amazing to me how
naturally makes it seem from like
beginning to end it seems like just a
normal conversation but it brings out
these topics that i would never think of
do you ever go into it thinking i'll ask
these questions or how do you take it in
that direction and get good at that i'll
write a bunch of questions down yeah but
i think you always have to be looking at
like who you are as an interviewer and
what your style is and to me joe rogan
when it comes to a lot of topics like
now when it comes to mma when it comes
to maybe like nutrition and working out
and stuff he's he's the expert you know
he knows everything realistically you're
probably not bringing anything to the
table he doesn't know about unless
you're a huge expert in that field but
then when he interviews you know a
rapper or a person like i heard i was
listening interviewed james hepfield
from metallica and i'm pretty sure at
one point in the interview he's just
like dude
this one song like i forgot what song it
is like that [ __ ] song rocks dude and
i'm like bro joe rogan is the alpha male
of normie interviews right here because
he's interviewing the [ __ ] from
metallica and he so clearly like didn't
even really cry into this guy's past at
all whereas if i was doing that
interview i want to do enough research
that i could feel like a metallica fan
is going to get something out of it and
not just be sort of rehashing whatever
but that's just my style is that i kind
of
want to be as informed as possible and
just as tapped in with as many different
subcultures in general and i mean really
i started doing interviews because i was
just spending so much time
sitting in my room watching
documentaries watching other people's
podcasts reading blogs for a while
before i started doing podcasts i want
to be a writer and i'm sitting in this
[ __ ] coffee shop for like eight hours
a day just just trying to write blog
posts and write articles and stuff and
uh at a certain point i just kind of had
the epiphany of like
i i think podcast is way more for me
like i shouldn't be sitting around
trying to figure out how to perfect a
sentence which is so much of what
writing is you know what we're doing
right now
if you were to transcribe this
and presented us like an article it
would be terrible it's like we're
thinking out loud you know so i found
that that was kind of way more my style
would you start doing it full time and
like that was your focus that was what's
paying the bills
i mean i've never had a job since i was
in high school
so
yeah when i was 22 i started doing that
bmx thing and i just kind of transferred
from that to no jumper around 2016 or so
2017 and you know we still have the bike
shop on melrose in la but uh we got rid
of that actually luckily like right
before the pandemic and uh we want to
make a return in that regard but uh not
not really sure exactly when or where
but yeah it pretty much
you know like i
i can't remember when the no jumper
thing actually started making a decent
amount of money but within like the
first year or two i was looking at it
and seeing it making you know two grand
five grand however much and then when it
really started to hit its stride those
because i was also doing these iphone
vlogs so an average day for me would be
wake up go to my shop
film clips talking to the fans film
clips of all the freaky that's going on
outside all these weird people out and
about in los angeles and hollywood and
then i'm also bouncing between doing
that to doing interviews in the back of
the store so like an average day
i might have been doing you know an
iphone vlog all day that i would then
edit that night and then also multiple
podcasts throughout the day so i was
just looking at that like this is this
is it i got up to like 50k a month from
doing that and then the adpocalypse hit
and that became 5k a month wow and that
was when i started to realize like i
have to do all kinds of stuff i have to
diversify i have to start live streaming
i have to start doing merch i have to
start doing a lot of different stuff
and um
yeah that just was very very important
in the development of everything because
you know even right then immediately i
landed on one of our biggest revenue
streams that i've made millions off of
which is we go on live stream and i it
started to occur to me like my dms are
flooded with people that want me to
listen to their music so we go on live
stream and people start sending 10 20
with their soundcloud link so we can
listen to their song and i think the one
one of the first time it might not been
the first time but one time we did it
was charging 20 dollars a song and we
stayed on for i think
12 hours and ended up making like
10 grand or something which is massive
to me at the time and then we just kind
of evolved from there now we charge 120
bucks per song i got like a whole cast
of me and my friends
we sit around we average around 2000
bucks an hour
and uh that that just was me being
reactive to the fact that i had all
these people sending me their music and
i was like okay well if you want me to
hear your music here you go you know
that's genius it is how much thought did
you put into the into the shot because i
remember watching your earlier videos
and i'm like where is this being filmed
and this is like a table with a whole
bunch of stuff everywhere and there's so
many people just like hanging out and
that's what that's
the best example of that the witch the
xxx centos interview because there's
people like uh
dj scheme who's still like a very
popular dj and producer and stuff you
just see him just sitting on a bike
because we didn't have enough chairs so
he had to sit on a bike for an hour
while we're doing that interview and
yeah in the beginning i didn't care
about aesthetics at all because keep in
mind that when i started almost nobody
was putting their podcast on youtube
everybody was audio first and when i
[ __ ] look back to that time period i
did a lot of like
sort of goofy in my opinion now as a
youtuber things like i filmed
four episodes before i went live so that
i would be able to put them all on the
iphone the podcast app at the same time
so that i would be able to rise up on
the charts or whatever i thought that
was super important at the time and uh
now i just focus on youtube although we
do we make a good amount of money off
the audio as well but
yeah that the the the visual part i just
figured you know if i have anything
that'll be
pretty good right but what about now
because you could if you could afford
like the top of the line set and like
professional people kind of like what
impulsive hazard you have one camera
yeah the one that moves
the other guy doing it and he has like
five people behind the scenes just like
tinkering with everything yeah we just
have a bunch of dslr's on tripods um
my guys who are editing for me they pop
up and they
settle the cameras up when i'm about to
do the interview i lock in i got one guy
running the obs and then
that's it i've always tried to keep the
actual podcasting like extremely low
cost just because you don't necessarily
make that much on youtube off of
a single interview especially when some
of the interviews don't really go crazy
and so i i don't know i care about the
way it looks but i'm also just not
really that pressed about making it look
incredible i don't know
there's there's got to be something to
be gained for it or i feel like there's
people out there that i see are kind of
making a name for themselves through
having really high quality but i don't
know that it really is going to move the
needle that much for us would you ever
do that or do you think it's more your
brand just to kind of have a relaxed
environment yeah exactly we're kind of
doing like a full redux of our filming
setup because we just bought this like
five million dollar office building near
our current spot and we're just sort of
rethinking everything and just putting
so much money into building out these
different studios and everything so
we're actually building like cool sets
and backgrounds and kind of rethinking
how we're going to approach the cameras
and everything like that so we're doing
a little bit more of it now but i also
just don't really think that's our
primary value add million dollars why
that's a big investment where could you
tell us where that is in l.a i'm
guessing by like downtown burbank
why why so much you know what before we
go and why so much why are there always
people hanging outside
like you walk outside there's like 10
people just like waiting so you're
thinking of the store this is the office
which is okay secluded and we have
security and nobody's allowed to come
there
um when there were people hanging out
outside i mean i seen some of the
weirdest [ __ ] i ever seen in my life
outside the store i mean people would
just
pull up
go to the weed store down the street and
then just sit outside and roll weed and
like you know at first i would be able
to stand outside of the store and have a
conversation with people and there was
nothing and as the months went by it
just became more and more if i went
outside for five minutes
there would already be a bunch of people
who wanted to take photos and then there
would be people who started pulling over
in their cars and all of a sudden were
40 deep
outside the store which i didn't have
security at the time i wasn't thinking
about anything like that
and it's you know it's just like a lot
of people want to make it in a creative
world right and like i mean if if you're
the biggest gram fan in the world like
how do you meet graham you probably just
don't or maybe you go to like a meet and
greet or a live event at some point
maybe you get to shake hands at some
point but it's very hard to like
approach or get exposure to the people
that you're looking up to right and so
you know just the fact that we had that
store just made us like way too
accessible
to people which you know it's nice to be
able to have that kind of relationship
with people but at a certain point it
just doesn't scale at all you're telling
me that lil xan was hanging around he
was stumbling around [ __ ] up off pills
yeah like he was just one of these
regular kids that was hanging out around
was this before he his career took off
yes and then one day his career blew up
and i was like how the [ __ ] did that i
didn't see it happening like i didn't
think it was like that kind of why was
he hanging around is it because he knew
that you were so big in the scene he
just wanted to make his presence known
yeah he there's like a photo from way
back in the day that was just like a fan
photo of him and me that's kind of crazy
to look back on just that he was
thinking about me like that and yeah he
just wanted to get his rap career going
so he was just kind of hanging around
you know
and he just blew up and then afterwards
you had him on the podcast and
everything and yeah like one of our
biggest videos is just interviewing him
that was after he blew up that was one
of my favorite videos i have to say i
think that's how i was introduced to you
was through the little xan video
yeah what was the once i'm um blanking
on the name the one song that uh
everyone betrayed betrayed it's a great
song
i really like it and i how could he
never do that again like not even to
talk [ __ ] about him but like
i never really understood but i would i
used to talk to his manager and he said
that he just wouldn't record he'd be
hanging out with like 10 girls a day he
just wouldn't record but he was like 18
when that song took off he was pretty
young yeah maybe he had less in his
system when that was when that song came
i think it is you you can't handle that
sort of attention and money at 18 and
conceptualize when you come from nothing
but also
he was really bad with drugs
and since he was really young which is
like
pretty much the whole story like if he
had been sober during that time period i
feel like he would have been able to
pull it together but he was the opposite
of sober yeah and it's rough when you
give someone like that in that position
access to anything that they would want
and for two years afterwards he could
pick anything and just be like i want
that and then do it i mean and there's
no one telling him no or maybe there are
but at that level you could afford just
to say all right well you know what go
away i remember i went and i was hanging
out with him and his former manager stat
quo and it was right before southwest
southwest and uh he had some shows
booked and it's i don't think that they
were like paid shows or they're like
pretty low paying shows you know and uh
stat was saying like we got to go
tomorrow we're going to south by
southwest and lil xan was like [ __ ] that
i make money online every day i don't
got to do that [ __ ] and i remember his
manager just saying like this show is
for genius you know like genius.com is
like [ __ ] big-ass platform they could
do a lot for you in terms of music and
stuff he's like if you don't go to the
show
they're not gonna [ __ ] with you again
they're not gonna care about you anymore
if you don't rub their back right here
and not even that but like you are
booked you said that you were gonna go
if you don't go it's gonna be really
really bad for your career and he didn't
give a [ __ ]
and i mean that's just not how you
become a popular artist most of the most
popular artists i know are people who
are kissing babies and shaking hands at
the radio stations
not always sometimes you're so popular
and cool that you don't have to do that
but
you know realistically he probably
should have done that it seems like in
the rap career it's pretty common that
someone like skyrockets and becomes
extremely popular very fast and then
like a lot of the times they'll drop off
what have you noticed uh like are the
main determinants of if someone's able
to continue going on that rocket ship of
success or something that usually leads
to a lot of people's downfall is it like
drugs is it ego is it other stuff like
that drugs and ego are a huge part but
also i would say that a lot of rappers
kind of blow up not off being rappers
without being memes and sometimes
there's like a song that is
the distillation of their personal meme
so the song is kind of like their whole
thing but then after that there's not
that much further for them to go with it
and even there's some popular rappers
that i can look at and i'm like
that guy doesn't have a second album in
him you know like his his value
proposition to the people right now is
just the fact that he has like a cool
voice cool style he's kind of got a
different flow but by the time you get
to album number two he's not going to be
able to keep people interested and a lot
of times that's how it happens and then
once in a while you'll find somebody who
actually is able to keep switching it up
and and keep the people interested and
that's you know enduring superstar and
even of the rappers who are big that
might be 10 of them or something like
that you know and uh
yeah it's just do you ever warn people
like if you see that sort of situation
like hey you got one great record do you
ever just say hey
be smart with it like i'm going to tell
you from my experience
it doesn't really work out i'm just like
don't blow it right now like play it
smart these next like two years i don't
really think it's my place to be doing
that
you kind of realize over time that
there's certain things
that might be true and correct
that you just don't have to do like like
one thing i realized kind of early on is
like i never need to be criticizing a
young rapper who's coming up it's just
not what people want from me it's not a
good look it's not doing anything for me
and it's it's the easiest lowest hanging
fruit and there's like a whole little
world of youtubers to make videos about
rappers falling off saying oh this guy
did a show and 10 people showed up or
this guy's album dropped and he sold 4
000 copies so he's a [ __ ] loser
whatever okay i probably agree with a
large percentage of those videos but for
me i feel like i'm much better suited to
be you know amplifying and helping
people in their career um
at least the majority of the time or at
least unless they disrespect me at which
point i'll usually just start being
honest now hasn't some of that changed
because it seemed like in the beginning
with bmx you were trash talking and that
was like a way in has that shifted now
you do you stay away from trash talking
or is it just like you've just grown
because i was trash talking the industry
right and i was talking about like just
for example one of the things that got
me in a lot of [ __ ] in the beginning was
that there was a
bmx awards show that they did and do
every year and i just did not agree with
some of the people who won because it's
like it's voted on by the industry so
you get these [ __ ] ass people
winning because all the people in the
industry are friends with each other and
they just vote for the [ __ ] that's
popular and there's even rumors about
you know that [ __ ] being rigged for the
sponsors and everything like that
and you know
i don't hold my tongue at all when i'm
talking about
nicki minaj i'm talking about drake when
i'm talking about you know because i
just have an opinion like they don't
[ __ ] care uh or if they do care so
what like you're famous i'm not gonna be
able to do anything that would
negatively impact your career but when
it's some girl that's coming out who's
got 20 000 followers it's just so much
more on brand and beneficial for me to
be the one who says
i think you have some talent i'm going
to give you an interview and help you in
this rise you know there's something to
be said for that i like being able to
play that role where but then sometimes
those people become gigantic superstars
and someday they might hear me having a
real opinion about their music or their
career or whatever and ideally by the
time they become millionaires they're
not going to be so so thin-skinned
although a lot of times they are that's
a good rule of thumb always punch up
never punch down it's just not a good at
least you have to be a millionaire right
or at least yeah be a millionaire at
least they're a millionaire yeah what do
you think of the island boys
i interviewed him before that the island
was how did you find them they were just
popular memes on on youtube and stuff
they were always going on instagram live
and just arguing with everybody and uh
this is before the song took off before
the song yeah which the song wasn't
really that big it was just the tick
tock of them doing the chorus of the
song and i remember thinking to myself
like is this below me like like is this
really beneath me to do this interview
with these guys because their music is
very very bad and uh but i thought they
were so funny and they were so viral
i was like dude i just i can't not do
this i did it and it got a couple
million views and i was pretty hyped on
it because then they really blew up
after that so i was like i'm very glad
that i got in there yeah early what was
your impression of them because i i
would love them to come on the iced
coffee hour i would love it uh i sent
them a dm they did not get back to me so
the uh the doors open they didn't see it
but
i think that they're um
frauds for sure you know like no
disrespect to them but they're running
around saying they're bloods
no they're like running around kind of
acting tough for a while it's like no
this is not i mean it's just like
you know they're cool they're kids
they're having a good time you know like
maybe the music will get better over
time but i mean they're
they're kind of dumb they're kind of
like just clueless as [ __ ] just i mean
like look at them they have the full
tattoo they look they got the kodak
black hair now they got [ __ ] the
lineup
do you think that they're actually smart
like underneath it all because like but
think about what they've done like
they've probably made a lot of money
they can't see
that they've seen a lot of success
you know
the fashion nova sponsorships yeah on
instagram i tried to calculate how much
money they made and i went through all
of their income and i tried to calculate
i guessed that they were making about
they they were on track to make about
one and a half million dollars total
between all of those between the two of
them so like you know 750 each if that
continued throughout the year right
maybe i mean yeah what are they going to
do with their fame from here you know
it's kind of
crazy
they were really cool
don't give them ideas they unfollowed me
when i uh well i didn't even do it
somebody on my news team posted the
video of them getting booed at the club
and they were extremely awesome i saw
that video anything to do with this this
happens to me all the time where people
are furious at me for something that one
of the people who works for me posts but
i mean it happened i don't know what's
so bad about
having attention called to it yeah yeah
geez do you ever worry about like
burning bridges like let's just say they
hear you say oh they're dumb this and
that does that ever worry you that like
all right now you've kind of lost not
lost that connection but like you're not
keeping the door open
in the future i guess with some people
i try to be a little bit more delicate
but i mean am i really gonna sit here
and lie to you and be like
more optimistic than i really am i mean
the [ __ ] people know
they know it's a crazy social media
world they know these guys are not
famous for their music if they do find
some other way for them to be enduring
personalities and parts of the culture
you know good for them like i'm not like
hating on them at all but i also
wouldn't really say that they're like
evil masterminds or anything like that i
would say that they're just kids who
kind of just became
famous from just being really [ __ ]
simple really
is there is there anyone you've had on
your podcast where you were like so
nervous to meet them or someone that
you're a huge fan of and it was a big
deal to you masterpiece
that's just one that comes to mind
because like
i had to [ __ ] pull some some tricks
to make it happen like there was a store
right next to ours who was doing a drop
of some like famous masterpiece album
art they were doing t-shirts with his
album covers or whatever and i get in
with the guy from the store and i tell
him i'm like can you make it part of the
deal with you doing this event for him
that he'll also stop by and do this
interview with me
and somehow this actually happened and
you know masterpiece is a massive human
who is
well i thought he was extremely rich at
the time there seems to be a debate
about that online now if he actually is
rich or not i don't really know where
that stands but uh you know he had all
these these guys were on all black pull
up before he got there scoping the place
out looking around like real deal
presidential security that i was very
impressed by and then he just comes in
and his demeanor is just so just
grizzled like he's just seen everything
and done it all
and yeah i was a little nervous for that
or even like something like joe budden
is like such a huge podcasting hero of
mine and then he just comes in but i
mean that's part of the challenge i try
to like i don't like meditate as much as
i should but i try to just be in this
extremely calm state when it comes to
doing the interview i try to just like
the thing i'm thinking about is like
breathe deep relax just be as
comfortable as possible because any
energy that you're wasting on being
nervous is useless it doesn't do
anything for you it's just
energy wasted but i mean sometimes i'll
have podcasts where i realize part way
through my hands are clammy
i'm [ __ ] sweating under the armpit
etc and i just try to try to keep it
cool and you know but that happens so
infrequently right i used to have that
feeling about everybody at first i was
nervous as [ __ ] to interview anybody and
that just slowly kind of dissipated
through doing a few thousand of these
you know who i was really nervous uh was
andrew hills remember that oh yeah the
chatting with because i had watched him
since like 2012. he's laugh on youtube
he did a lot of prank stuff yeah oh okay
yeah yeah someone like you had seen yeah
growing up
and like that kind of shaped like that
really helped get me into youtube so to
like to meet that person yeah who was
like that's crazy well i was like wow
it's it's him like that was scary for me
but okay this is also part of it is that
i could never be ner i never be that
nervous to interview you because you're
a youtuber you talk on camera i'll
probably never be nervous to interview a
podcaster a comedian uh whatever because
i mean this is what they do like your
kind of job is to think of [ __ ] to talk
about sometimes i'll have a rapper who's
really young
and really
not that conversational but their music
is really really popping at that time
and people want to see me interview them
and sometimes you get into that
environment and they start one word
answering you and then it becomes like
you know how do you
coax something out of them how do you
get them to open up to you a little bit
and uh sometimes i'll become nervous in
those ones because you have to start
filling the the timeline with you
talking more to make up for the fact
that they're giving you these short ass
answers and like how do you break them
out of that box
but you know i feel like usually when
that happens the audience blames it on
them not me so sure at least if i put my
best foot forward that that can be good
do you think it's just they're nervous
or that they just don't want to be there
or that's just naturally them of just
like yep yeah i think they're just a lot
of times when they're young they're just
they don't have great conversational
skills and then even beyond that
a lot of times so many times i've had
people come on the podcast and they
think that they're just gonna smoke a
shitload of weed before the podcast and
during the podcast and like there's this
thing where
if i'm sitting at home alone smoking
weed watching tv
i don't notice the change in myself
because i'm not really doing anything
i'm just sitting here but if you're
sitting on camera with the bright lights
on you and you're just high as [ __ ] a
lot of times because people are lying to
themselves because there are rappers who
just literally smoke once all day and it
doesn't really impact them that much
honestly i could have been smoking weed
all day right now and you guys probably
wouldn't really know but
some dudes do this and they don't
realize how bad on camera it makes them
to be high
not to mention oh my god the lean oh the
lean or the pills if somebody's doing
that like i remember one time i
interviewed this rapper sosa geek from
brooklyn and he uh i had watched another
interview with him where he was clearly
on some kind of upper
and it was great it was he was just
talking non-stop and then i interviewed
him and he walks in drinking lean
and it's a downer and
it was you know not great it was
certainly not his best interview you
know just slows you down to a crawl that
[ __ ] you know what was the weirdest
thing that you've seen or have you ever
been in a position where like i gotta
cut this i can't
i can't post it
yeah i mean yeah definitely there's been
a lot of stuff i mean we used to do the
pods live yeah and i remember uh boonk
aka john gabbana yeah oh my gosh
we're live oh my gosh i forgot about him
we were live what happened to that he
pulls up
and he he could barely get a sentence
out and like i'm just like bro i'm not
doing an interview with you like this
you're [ __ ] up bro like you need to
you need to go get some sleep or
something like this is not it's not okay
and he just like kind of forced himself
into the chair and it was just babbling
and it was terrible and then as soon as
he gets up he just boom he [ __ ]
passes out and smacks his head
on the wall right there and that was one
of the most viral things that we ever
had happen because i remember the next
the next week i was in hawaii and like
the waiters at the restaurants like a
couple of them said something about it
to me and i was just like well this [ __ ]
has traveled to the the working-class
waiters of hawaii that means that
apparently it's pretty big wow are you
ever excited when someone walks in and
you just know it's gonna be a
catastrophe
because like that's where the real viral
moments can hit yeah gosh
i would rather have a great conversation
and go viral that way yeah for them to
be [ __ ] up you know especially for me
now where if it's really bad i might
just not put it out or yeah you know
like the ones where they just embarrass
themselves like the bunk one was the one
where it was so extreme and it might not
have been that viral but then he hit his
head on the wall and then it was viral
what happened to him because i remember
i used to watch his instagram videos and
he found jesus
and he's a boxer now are you serious i
watched him beat the [ __ ] out of supreme
patty and unboxing well he beat sabrina
patty
oh my god that's a name i haven't heard
yeah
wow i did a lot of fighting as a young
did you really so much like we just just
fight all the time since i was like
elementary school all the way up through
my like early twenties i'm getting bar
fights
do you ever get into like an actual like
damaging fight
yeah
bad
what was that yeah what was that like
i mean i just remember i was one night
where i got a photo some guys in a bar
in um in austin texas with a bunch of my
friends and this guy just like started
something with me and i remember i just
wound up and just punched him in the
face and i remember i felt my hand
really like enter his mouth and like all
his teeth got knocked out and then i ran
up out of there
and
i realized one of my friends didn't make
it out with me and i'm with my
girlfriend at the time too and oh him
and all his friends run back on they
beat the dog [ __ ] out of me and uh like
really jumped me back and i can hear my
friends attacking them while they're
jumping me and i remember just being
curled up in a ball just like waiting to
get knocked out and it never happened
and i was when i went and also i could
tell that the dude who i knocked his
teeth out was one of the guys beating
the [ __ ] out of me because he had my
sweater was just soaked in blood that
was clear like pouring out of his mouth
and then the girl because i went to new
york the next day i had a flight to
catch and i remember the girl just
telling me that she saw him a couple
days later with his jaw wires shut
and uh
yeah that was near the end what was the
fight over i could never imagine getting
getting like that angry nothing like
like he said something to me in the bar
like he he overheard me he was drunk and
he overheard me saying something about i
was talking about a friend of mine who
owned a bar and i was just saying i'm
like yeah my buddy owns his bar and yeah
and the guy walked by me and he goes
nice name drop
or something like that
so that was enough at that time in my
life to chase him down and attack oh my
god
so so he said nice name drop and then
you went up to him after that and just
yeah just walking sped over there like
10 seconds later i'm like in this heated
confrontation with him yeah oh so you
caught you confronted him first and then
and then he started
he put his hand on my shoulder and that
was when i was just like
and i remember i had a beer mug in my
other hand like sort of like this and i
remember that after i punched him in the
teeth i just looked at his friend and
just went
boom and just broke it on his head and i
had all these holes in my hand from the
from the mug
i don't know what i was thinking you get
in trouble for that no never no never
never been arrested as an adult well one
time and i got i got away with it easily
okay what
a lot of questions now what'd you get
arrested for as an adult i was on a bmx
road trip and uh there were two girls
who lived in manhattan that agreed to
let me and like eight dudes stay at
their house they had a really nice
apartment uh middle of midtown manhattan
great area super nice area and uh
one of my little homies who's like 19 or
something
he's kicking in with one of those girls
and they're getting drunk together and
apparently like at some point they think
it's funny they start throwing corona
bottles up the window we're like 30
floors up
and um they had a two-story apartment
which is very rare in manhattan that
basically says a lot about how rich
these kids are these girls parents were
and um and it was like their first week
at college like they hadn't even started
classes yet and i'm downstairs with a
friend [ __ ] making out with her or
something and i start seeing lights
flash outside so i i look down and i see
like a couple of cops
down there i think you know whatever
i start seeing more lights i go and look
again there's way more cops one of those
beer bottles hit a cab oh no and so the
cops come the cops start pointing the
lights they figure out which apartment
it is they storm up in there the girls
the girl's uh roommate lets the cops in
um
all my guys are asking me what do we do
and i tried to do the right thing i said
don't snitch on the girls because if you
snitch on them then we're not going to
be able to stay here and if you don't
snitch on them there's no way they're
arresting 12 people in this apartment
right
which seemed like a safe assumption it
was not accurate because they arrested
all of us
yeah we did like 24 hours in the
local jail what do you get arrested for
i mean why would they do that because
they could vandalism or something yeah
they couldn't prove it they couldn't
prove anything and that's what i was
telling them i'm like how are they ever
going to prove through the bottle right
you know they're not going to be able to
it's more just but they're mad so they
arrested us anyway and made us sit
around for 24 hours and then i remember
one of my friends hired like a 10 000
lawyer to represent him but all of us
like everybody else would just use
public defender because it was so clear
to me that we're going to be able to
beat this like nothing that's the only
time i ever got arrested as an adult
yeah wow
and i remember there was a clip that
went super viral of you doing your
podcast and someone showed up with a
weapon you know can you walk us through
what that was like for you so that thing
we do where we play people's music yeah
um
we were doing that one night you know
i'm just hanging out everybody's smoking
chilling there's probably five or six
dudes there in the back of the bike shop
and we ordered some post mates the
postmates comes my guy goes outside and
he grabs it and as he's opening the door
this dude sneaks in who was kind of
hiding in the in the corner back there
and he runs towards me with this gun and
starts pointing my head and like you see
in the clip that i'm kind of like
covering up and i go like i made this
like weird noise like i don't know this
is like nervous reaction or what but the
thing you can't see on camera that was
kind of trippy is that my guy is got his
gun out pointed at the dude's head so by
the time i see this dude running at me
i'm also thinking like oh my god this
dude's about to get murdered right in
front of me right now and somehow the
guy did not pull the trigger which is
his own personal situation but then
i don't know we beat the [ __ ] out of the
guy and then he he the gun ended up
being fake
we called the cops the cops like didn't
even want to come they didn't i'm like
what am i supposed to do i'm supposed to
drag this unconscious person into the
alley and leave them there and the cops
are almost saying yes i'm like no you
need to come here there's a weapon
there's a it ended up being fake but
whatever and uh i actually ended up
going to court about it but then i got
dismissed before i even was able to say
anything why did the cops not want to
come
i guess just because melrose is a
[ __ ] free-for-all and keep in mind
this is way like crime is so much worse
in hollywood and particularly on melrose
and they just didn't seem to think that
it sounded like something that they
should care about and and then even when
they came
they clearly didn't know anything about
me or what was going on in this
operation here which is fine but to me
if you're a cop in this area where
there's already like a bunch of
incidents that had happened at the store
it was like this just proves to me that
you guys are really you know really
clueless that you don't know anything
about what's going on here but
i don't know what happened to the dude
or anything what did he break in was it
to rob you guys or was he angry or just
mentally i think he was [ __ ] up on
drugs he had dm like a couple dozen
times and i'd never even seen it or
opened it
so i guess you want some attention i
don't know what did that feel like to
have a gun pointed at you at least that
you thought was real i mean it's like
you spent a lot of your time thinking
like oh like i'm not famous like that
you know like i don't need security like
i don't need to have people around me
with guns and [ __ ] like that like but
then
that was just kind of this wake-up call
of like oh maybe it is real like maybe i
actually am like notable enough that i
need to move around a certain way at
least when i'm in this environment when
i think about that now i mean the fact
that the fact that we were that easily
run up on a bull
it's just insane like why like i just
take my security so much more serious
and i say that i'm out in vegas right
now with no security and nobody with me
and i'm just because i was like thinking
about i'm like am i really gonna have
security out here and i'm gonna be
sitting at the poker table for like
eight hours a day and what is the
security going to do i don't know but in
la like at our office now we have
guys like take care of us i mean it
would make sense at an office where
people could figure out where you are
and show up there but would you do do
you have security when you go around la
i wouldn't say i have security but i'm
usually with a large gentleman who's
looking after me so have you ever had an
incident or no
i mean there was that yeah
um oh yeah one time i was uh sitting in
a a nail salon next to my store and this
is like 2017. i didn't know it wasn't
clear to me how big i was yet or
whatever and uh
this is just something i would never do
now and i just went in this nail salon
and i was getting a manicure
and then some guys ran up in there and
one of them just punches me in the face
from the side and i like i think he hit
me one more time as i went down
and i just like look up and i see them
running away and i'm just like what the
you know i couldn't believe it and then
i ended up figuring out like a year
later that this rapper who i had talked
pretty bad about
had sent these guys to pay me a visit
so yeah that was another important
learning moment of nobody's gonna catch
me lacking ever again wow
yeah parts of la have really degraded
and gone downhill i mean i know
that melrose area
i've seen because i i grew up in los
angeles and i've just seen the
decay over the last well especially last
like three years it's gotten really bad
do you know if they've cleaned it up now
or they're making an effort to
help with that situation it seems like
it's just crime has been getting worse
and i've been hearing more and more and
more reports now it's it's become a
common in beverly hills and hollywood
believe it or not um what people will do
is they'll stock really nice cars mm-hmm
and then would you believe in a strip
club because you have kids
right stuff like that but even just like
someone's leaving from work they park
their car in a lodge or they go out to
dinner and then what what will happen is
that there'll be a car that'll follow
them back home
and usually a lot of these wealthier
houses will have gates or whatever the
garage door the girl open up and they
just run in behind
where they see them open the door and as
soon as they open the door they run up
but you know the crazy part too is that
everybody has the cameras out in front
of their house and stuff now so there's
always like a video element of it
because when i think about it though
like like it's just so normal for us now
that we're always sharing videos of
crimes that are taking place at people's
houses and stores or whatever in la and
uh
part of me wonders like if it's just
well i know that the crime rate is up in
general but part of me wonders if
there's just more video evidence because
nobody would really care if there wasn't
you know but the i don't know i don't
think so i've seen
because
these were all the areas that i worked
for like 12 years and now i'm seeing
it's just non-stop of like people
getting their watches ripped off of them
if they're just like sitting down
someone will come up and just you know
point a knife and just like take off the
watch there's another guy a video on
beverly beverly drive in beverly hills
the guy's in his ferrari and someone
comes up yanks him out of the car at a
red light and takes his watch
yeah i mean it's great i've never seen
it that bad before there's a girl i know
who is a rapper she wears a bunch of
jewelry and she was with security the
other day and dudes ran up on her and
took all her jewelry and stuff and um
there was some debate about maybe the
security was in on it or something like
that but
i mean yeah that like sometimes i have
people who are like why don't you wear
diamonds why don't you have like a big
chain i'm like yeah i don't want to
bring that kind of energy around me at
all that feels like such a liability
like to just be walking around with that
much money on you like i just don't find
that attractive in general yeah have you
ever wanted to leave california i don't
think i could because i just kind of
need to be where the people are at so
it's been interesting seeing like miami
and austin become so much more relevant
or even vegas i guess to an extent
memphis
memphis yeah i don't really like to
travel to do my podcast because i feel
like i'm kind of
i like to like let people come to me
i don't know there's never like one
piece of content that i want so bad that
i'm willing to go travel for a few days
to get it done usually
um
but yeah leaving i don't know i don't
think i could do it and plus like my
girls like her family is like such a big
deal with her uh because she's armenian
it's like they're just they're so tied
in and for her to leave i mean it would
be like such a trail of everything that
they believe in i don't think i could
leave yeah but spending five million
bucks for a new set that's all that's a
lot of money porn money
that's a lot let's talk about let's talk
about your different business structures
and verticals that you have going on
because i know also you guys do only
fans
can you talk
about like percentage-wise where the
money comes from from your different
revenue streams well
the nice thing is that with no jumper we
bring in a pretty significant amount of
money but also you know i got all these
editors i got filmers i got all these
different hosts who make uh content on
the platform and everything so the money
gets divided up decently you know we
still make pretty good money but then uh
with plug talk which is my only fan's
podcast
we have one employee
realistically we probably don't even
need one employee we could do it all
ourselves if we wanted i'm trying to
hire more people just because it's
growing pretty rapidly but uh
yeah at one point um maybe uh i'm
thinking in 2019 or like right before
the pandemic um there's this guy vitaly
youtuber yeah yeah and he had a site
called a vitalion sensor yep and the the
team behind that they were reaching out
to me because they wanted me to do my
own version of it and uh his thing was
kind of like pranks but then there would
be some boobs exposed at a certain point
or something like that i've never seen
it it sound i mean no offense of a
television i heard you was making 500
000 a month from that site i would be
very skeptical of that exactly that's
what he said on that's what he said on
impulsive
yeah i would be very skeptical of that
having talked to the people involved and
everything like that but who knows maybe
he had a 500 000 month i don't know i'm
telling you that that's not out of the
question for us at all that's kind of
regular for us at this point but um they
they wanted us to do something that was
you know
a podcast where the girls took their
boobs out at some point me and my girl
just kept talking about it and i was
like hey i don't think we need this
company and b
i think we need to [ __ ] the girls after
we interview them because otherwise it's
just fake like otherwise somebody else
is going to do that and it's like why
wouldn't we just take it to the logical
extreme you know we know all these porn
strut girls we know that they would do
this kind of content who else is poised
like i do interviews you're a famous
porn star like my girl only works with
me but you know and other girls but you
know i was just like we could just do
this and we uh we had a lot of delays
because she got pregnant as we were kind
of gearing up to do this but yeah we
drop an episode a week and for me i i
think of it as like right now it's just
this weekly podcast that you get to see
the full version on only fans but i have
so many ideas for just like holes in the
adult marketplace that i think we could
fill in terms of additional content and
i just really am excited to kind of turn
it into this like vibrant
porn media company because i feel like
porn is so much more mainstream now and
there's so much growth to be had in it
but
a lot of people in the industry are
maybe not that forward thinking you know
because they just i know so many people
just just rake in money just making
content that realistically doesn't
require any sort of
thought or anything like that you know
people just pay for porn um pretty
consistently
and uh
yeah that's that's kind of become a
thing we do a lot of variety now too
where sometimes uh the other day we
interviewed a couple together that does
porn together and then they had sex with
each other after and that was a really
interesting interview to find out the
dynamic of their relationship and you
know sometimes we'll do uh interviews
with girls where uh we'll have a guy
come in and like we had we interviewed a
girl the other day who lost her uh peach
emoji virginity on the podcast with a
guy afterwards which was pretty cool
and um
imagine doing this check
i got this new idea for the podcast a
lot of people
can't even fathom it and to me it is so
second nature it's so easy oh my gosh
like in comparison to a day where i'm
just talking on camera
those days feel incredibly easy like i'm
just so super laid back and relaxed the
whole time because it's so it's like
from a from a monetary perspective it's
genius
like i'm sure you guys are raking it in
so i'm confused so
you're interviewing somebody
at the table and then like halfway
through they decide to
well it's kind of or they talk it
through or we do the interview because
it's like a mic situation where we're
wearing the clip-on mics for the
interview and then at a certain because
we don't want to have to have like a
desk with mics because then you can't
see the girl or whatever and then at a
certain point we just sort of break for
a couple minutes so that we could switch
to the boom mic and then we get into it
you know although i would really like to
make it smooth enough that we could just
transition right from the conversation
into the sex but the mic situation like
i'm just i'm not going to use a boom mic
for the podcast it's going to sound like
[ __ ]
and i refuse like yeah yeah and then we
can't wear lapel mics all right this is
just stupid but like uh when when
they're doing their their show you know
do you ask them
questions do you continue the interviews
no no no
although sometimes
it is more talkative than you'd think
like sometimes there is a decent amount
of conversation flowing afterwards yeah
how much does that make
many many many hundreds of thousands a
month i guess is a simple way to say it
and
my girl obviously is 50 50 with me on it
yeah we both are very happy with it yeah
and we manage girls under that umbrella
you know i'm sure you drive a lot of
traffic too from no jumper to the only
fans
yeah but also it's kind of its own
entity like if you if you subscribe to
no jumper on youtube you would never
know unless you just heard me mention it
in a random podcast we have one clip per
week like we'll take like a 10-minute
clip and on the weekend we'll drop it
from the plug talk thing just to
give it some extra exposure but yeah
it's not really
i like it because over the years we've
always just had porn stars on and then
the fans like who just want to see rap
interviews are complaining and acting
like we're sort of like you know
invalidating the whole purpose of the
channel by interviewing porn stars as
well and for me it was kind of nice to
be able to say okay
let's
segment this up we still have some porn
stars on uh no jumper from time to time
but usually only like really big names
wow so how many people do you have
employed
like what's the how's the business
structured geez i don't know maybe like
10 in-house and then we have a bunch of
freelance people and a bunch of people
that we kind of pay to do stuff i don't
know it would be hard to say it could be
like 15.
okay
can we talk numbers at all in terms of
like
are you comfortable sharing any of that
sure i don't care what is it what does
the whole brand
make in in a month or in a year
i mean
no jumper might bring in a million a
month
wow
and then plug talk
not quite as much but
in the ballpark
arena of that wow yeah where is it we do
that yeah you got to consult us
is it sponsorship revenue not really
that that's how we would get to two
million a month is if we had a [ __ ]
barstool sports type ad sales team
really blanking in our [ __ ] and ads no i
mean a big part of it's patreon you know
we have a patreon that does six figures
a month facebook has been insane
we're making a couple hundred grand a
month on facebook youtube does good our
clips channel all of a sudden that's
just posting the podcast on facebook a
full podcast we have a team that'll take
the interviews and cut them into these
like four minute clips and they're super
good at making it pop off like it feels
like everything they post on facebook
will do a million views so that team
should
use their services for other podcasts
they do
you want to get hooked up yeah i tried i
tried doing that for my videos and it
did horribly and i realized that
facebook's audience is so vast that my
segment for like young
20s
30-somethings for personal finance is
not there on facebook they're not there
on facebook they're on instagram youtube
i bet there's a strategy that could get
your [ __ ] in front of them i think
facebook wants you to pay money to reach
your audience so to reach a i don't know
i know a lot of people doing really good
business on there and it's totally lost
on me how they do it because i always
posted stuff on facebook and
would do okay i mean my goal because we
have a bunch of different facebook pages
in the works
my personal uh branded facebook page
like we're converting from a personal
account to like a page or however that
works we're doing a plug talk account
etc um
trying to see how we can do with the bmx
side of things on there but i mean
my guy who i do the facebook thing with
me told me he's like i think you can
make a million a month from just
facebook
gosh we got to do that jack yeah i'm
actually very down to talk about that
what do you offer on patreon so we do
we do one episode per week where we have
a different uh only fans girl or
whatever and it's not plug talk because
there's no sex but they get naked or
they do crazy stuff whatever so it's
kind of like one uncensored episode
per month and then um we released the
audio from some of the podcasts early or
like um no the the actual interview is
on there early sometimes but the
majority of it is just the fact that we
have
naked girls on there which i know you're
thinking it sounds very redundant with
plug talk except that they're not having
sex but
it turns out they don't care i guess
the audio version you know i never have
put really an emphasis on the on the
audio version but there's this company
megaphone that we signed with that's a
spotify company or whatever and they
insert ads into your podcast so it's not
like the ones you're reading like you
can you can add the ad breaks or
whatever and that that's been really big
for us it's just a combination of a
bunch of things but the facebook thing
was really what put us over the top
because it's almost like more money than
we make on youtube where i've been
grinding away day in day out for like
six seven eight years wow facebook and
snapchat snapchat's pretty good to us um
try that yeah our tick dock has been
doing really well yeah the iced coffee
hour does really well on short form
graham's main channel stuff doesn't
surprisingly it doesn't do quite as well
but the tick tock stuff it's like you
clip it up and whoever guest you have on
their audience also like the tick al the
tick tock algorithm will just like find
them immediately right so those do
extremely well yeah and we've spent a
good amount of money getting our tick
tock up to where it's at now i think we
have like 1.6 million or whatever but we
have not monetized it in any real way
shape or form yeah it's not good for
monetization it's just brand awareness
yeah what do you do with all the money
nothing
save it invest it
where do you invest it
uh
real estate stocks crypto i'm not
i don't personally spend a ton of time
on thinking about it i just have a team
or a business manager who helps me
do the right stuff with it i'm very
confident in him so yeah what sort of
real estate to you on uh the house i
live in now okay like a couple million
on that uh and then we bought this big
warehouse and i'm just planning on
probably doing more of that and i just
want to own more stocks more crypto more
real estate in general you know it's not
crypto when you start buying crypto not
i don't have like a cool crypto story i
just have like a couple of 100 grand and
it's just been sort of rocking there not
gaining or losing much value the whole
time i've had it in there is it what is
it a bitcoin ethereum yeah both yeah got
it yeah i kind of missed out on man i i
look at all the rappers who
were able to pull off these crazy crypto
promotion things oh gosh and on one hand
i'm like jeez i'm so glad that i like
kept my integrity intact and didn't do
those but then at the same time i know a
lot of people who did it and
really didn't experience that much
backlash because it was early enough
and you know coffeezilla can only target
so many people you know you're gonna
have to say you'll end up with coffee
zillow yeah like my girl
my girl turned down like half a million
for an nft thing uh
six months ago or however many months
ago and i remember tana i'm like it's
not worth it
they're going to make videos about you
you don't want to be a [ __ ]
advertisement for this [ __ ] and she you
know okay i'll trust you and the exact
deal that she did is the thing that lana
or that she didn't do is the thing that
lana rhodes did
that she's getting because they're
they're friends and like seeing lana
rhodes get turned into this [ __ ]
billboard
of like what a nft scam is
has been pretty crazy but i mean like
soulja boy was selling nfts of all of
his old tweets in the beginning and
people were buying them and stuff like
soulja would probably make so many
millions of dollars doing these stupid
things that nobody even remembers
because it's easier to go after jake
paul or logan paul or steve will do it
or whoever you know like coffeezilla or
whoever is going to
target the
big obvious
superstar dudes you know even if my girl
had done that
lana rhodes is like a lot more famous
than my girl i guess so realistically
she might have still just been the one
to take the [ __ ] for it correct but who
knows steve will do it someone i would
love to meet too have you met him good
guy yeah we did a video we interviewed
like before they were big i remember
them uh
they their idea was to dress up as
soundcloud rappers and come to an event
at my store and basically troll the fans
and just say crazy stuff to them and get
them to fall for it but this was like
one of the times where they realized
that even if they were wearing disguises
that they were too famous and they
weren't going to be able to pull this
off anymore so uh
that was kind of crazy to see them have
that realization yeah yeah i have so
much respect for nelk and everything
they have done it's incredible i love
listening to the interviews with um with
kyle just any podcast he did he did one
with a canadian channel and they were
they were really small they had like i
watched that yeah 10 000 subscribers but
they were from their hometown and like
we just want to support and it was one
of the coolest interviews i've listened
to it's to get into the mind of kyle
like how he sees everything as a
business and beyond all the parting and
the drinking like he's so smart and
strategic with everything he does like i
really respect that and they really
doubled down on like just creating a
brand and not worrying about that
short-term youtube money you know their
videos are geared to be as entertaining
as possible they're like mr beast in
that way too where like i'm just gonna
make the best stuff i'm gonna build the
coolest brand and
i'll do that whereas like so many of the
earlier generation of youtubers were
just i'm gonna make a video per day
because i'm making ten thousand dollars
a video and i'm gonna grind this [ __ ]
until i have a couple million and then
i'm probably gonna stop because i'm you
know it's so taxing doing this day after
day and to see nell have such a bigger
vision's been pretty crazy and i
remember on that interview i think i
wanted to go an hour and i think we only
went like 40 minutes or something like
that
they didn't strike me at that time as
being
people who were gonna do a really great
podcast but kyle he kills it he's been
doing great yeah i agree it's it's been
cool to see their evolution too because
i remember them going just from quick
pranks to then the storyline behind the
pranks and they were i believe they were
one of the first people to like here's
leading up to the prank and we're going
to be going to this party and sleeping
on someone's couch and okay now we're
going to do the prank and here's it
afterwards and we're going to run away
and we're going to and they created like
this whole 20-minute story line
around a 2-minute prank and then briefly
they tried doing like scripted content
and it was interesting to see how how
quick they pivoted because everyone in
the comments like this ain't it sorry i
could see you're trying like i just hate
this content go back to this but you
could tell they're listening in every
single video and they're like all right
they didn't like this let's tweak it a
little bit definitely they developed
that so well and they were just smart
about
aligning themselves with people who
could do things that were too big for
them to take on themselves like with the
happy dad thing yeah the fact that they
just went and linked up with a really
serious team who could get something
like that done and that's i'm just
amazed by that it's really impressive
i'm curious if they got offers for
buyouts on that i i'd like 100 someone
should have made an offer or i bet they
did and they probably turned it down to
buy that yeah because i mean the next
couple years of growth yeah they got
that for sure i feel like at some point
maybe it gets so big but they aren't
able to really like run it themselves
but it feels like the people they
partnered with are
experienced enough that you know if they
do sell it's going to be the [ __ ]
budweiser
huge company you know do you have any
other advice for us is uh uh trying to
continue to grow the podcast
we've we've uh like what difficulties
have we had jack i would say our big one
is um making sure that we have exciting
guests on that we ask the right
questions we we try to play to the
strengths of the algorithm sometimes and
uh but our thing is like how do we keep
improving and one-upping and
yeah i mean
one of the things that i think about a
lot and i was thinking about this when i
was listening to you talk about what
your days are like of like really being
focused in on your video for the day and
listening and you talk about how much
time you put into thinking of the titles
and the thumbnails and stuff
i love that but at a certain point it
started to really click with me that
like i can only do so much on camera and
i i just needed to build a team and i
needed to start like embracing some of
the people i was meeting to make content
for me you know and i feel like i could
i don't know if that's necessarily a
logical
process for you but i think that like
getting people under your umbrella and
even with plug talk like i have this big
idea that we're working on right now
where we're gonna have a separate
podcast that people can pay extra for
where we have these two girls that we
manage and they're going to interview
male porn stars and then [ __ ] them on
camera afterwards and i mean i'm just
like this is amazing because if i can
make this happen then that could be
content that we're making on a day where
i'm off doing no jumper content and i'm
not even there and i mean that's kind of
how i see it now is like a lot of times
i just in my schedule i'll be like
wednesday i'm not doing anything i'm
working with my team and i'm reviewing
people who've sent in their information
that want to do stuff on camera because
if i can find even one person that's
good on camera they might make me you
know 100 hours worth of content this
year and uh that's just really valuable
and you know if i if i really focus on
just doing as much as possible i think i
have seen the limits of that for myself
because i've i've had days where i did
five podcasts where i was on camera for
like 10 hours straight and i've had days
i've had weeks where i did you know 10
12 podcasts in a week and that's not the
only and some of them are plug talk
episodes where i'm also having sex and
i've like i've really burnt myself out
as much as i possibly could to the point
where
uh you know
taking a one week off vacation was like
the hardest thing i could have possibly
done at that time and i don't really
feel that way anymore i feel very much
more like
content with
being a little bit more moderate with my
behavior and i think having a kid really
helped me a lot with that because it's
just something that i needed to slow
down and i needed to be able to like
enjoy
the simple things in life a little bit
more and my kid has kind of forced me to
do that because i just realized within
the first couple months of like if i
keep working every weekend i'm just
never really going to see my kid grow up
and so i've kind of found like a better
pace at this how do you balance the two
i pretty much just work 10 hours a day
or 12 hours a day monday through friday
and try to get that
time in in the morning
and then saturday and sunday i usually
just have cleared and sometimes i'll
have to go do something during that time
but i mean it's just really forced me to
like look at what i'm doing with my time
and just make these decisions i have so
many friends that still go to the club
and they swear up and down that the club
is just such a valuable networking
experience that you just have to do it
if you want to stay relevant in this
game and i'm just like i can't justify
staying out until three in the morning
doing anything never mind uh
just hanging out you know it's not fun
to me like i want to be advancing in my
life etc and so yeah i've just kind of
like
found how to cut as much stuff out of my
life as possible to be able to focus on
things that seem like they matter
um
yeah and i mean but like you know
certain things are the casualties of
that like on my personal youtube channel
i've barely posted for the last year or
two and that's one thing i really want
to do is just find somebody who can help
me script videos and like really
help me just make that more consistent
so that i can be
voicing the videos and maybe not
necessarily being the one writing them
because i love writing i love to sit and
yeah what are the scripted videos you do
i did a bunch of them where
you know i was like reacting to people's
only fans for some reason well that was
like the entry clickbait but it's really
just like kind of like a venue for me to
talk about whatever and i remember i did
like a half hour video about this porn
star brian pumper who just had like the
most ridiculous life story ever and i
felt like it wasn't
properly documented online so i just i
might have spent a month researching
this guy just so that i can i could just
write this ridiculous video about him
and ended up getting like a million
views and i was very happy that i could
have that many people paying attention
to a male porn star's life story i had
to slip my pumper in there my fans are
going to be like he mentioned him he had
to do it brian pumper
what a name
is real name
oh yeah yeah yeah i figured
wow so you're honest and you you've
watched the main my main channel i mean
your honest advice is to find someone to
script those videos that i'm doing
because it's so intricate i mean if you
watch it you'd see the i wouldn't say
that like you should do that because
obviously your channel is just your baby
and it's just
so clearly it's coming from your mind
but i do think that the most important
thing that i've had to figure out and
i've been kind of slow to figure it out
is that you just got to figure out how
to delegate responsibility and you got
to find people who can
do the do certain things for you that
you wouldn't that you're doing yourself
you just have to be able to clear up
more and more time i was just recently
doing a lot of research into hiring an
executive assistant i saw somebody on
some podcast recommend that and i
started really
researching that and and i just feel
like that would be the key to making me
way more productive like i still write
all of our titles and review the
timestamps and come up with the clips
and everything like that i feel like
that's something where if i hired
somebody who could do all that stuff for
me on every episode
that that would be uh
really helpful in terms of just clearing
up more time that i could be on camera
more doing more stuff that i'm kind of
uniquely
available to do yeah it's interesting
for me it's uh it's emails that take up
my time but some of those emails it's
like well i gotta respond to those
emails just because it's why just
because like someone else would be
asking me what do i say to this i would
just dictate the message anyway but if
you have an assistant that you really
trust yeah to be able to like answer a
lot of your emails for you and forward
them to the right places and really like
i feel like that's something that if i
were to clear that up in my life yeah
then i would be able to put a lot more
time into creative things but i mean i'm
really excited to get a story again
because i have this vision like we
always made content out of the store and
like when i think about a store i don't
think of it as like you know we sell
stuff and we can make money selling
stuff but that's never going to be the
real backbone of it you know i want to
make content out of there and i really
want to get a store and do a live stream
out the back of the store and then be
able to interact with the customers in
the front of the store
like having a camera yeah a bunch of
characters getting ready to talk to them
and create content off of like we never
really made that much content with all
these strange people that were coming to
the store aside from maybe getting a
clip here or there and i just feel like
there's
i don't know it's just
the content machine
i feel like could be operating a little
bit more effectively and yeah we were
gonna get this one store and then this
the landlord was such a nightmare to
deal with it i think we just pulled back
and just said hey we're going to find
something else because it's just not
going to work long term where do you
want to be 10 years from now where do
you see yourself i really don't know
it's just it would be nice to think that
i
would have enough money that i wouldn't
really have to be that concerned with
hustling but then like the thing that is
the most profitable for me to do most
days is also pretty much my favorite
thing to do like days where i go in and
i do
three interviews in a day or
you know i feel like so incredibly
content i feel like when i look at how i
went in this direction it was really
because
i
wanted to do something that i could do
over and over and over and never get
sick of and i have a lot of friends who
run brands where maybe they have a logo
and the the basis of their entire life
is putting that logo on different things
and coming up with different logos and
different products and coming up with
cool
you know ways to market it and promote
it and stuff like that and i really
really respect that but i don't know
that that would have kept me entertained
in the long run like i just need to be
talking to somebody new
every day
and uh or not every day but just all the
time the more people that i can get to
know on camera and i feel like it makes
me a better person like i feel like i
i'm sitting there in the chair reminding
myself to breathe deep and
not think about myself for a couple
hours and just really focus in on like
how can i
humanize this person or what's the
what's the best thing that i could pull
out of this person right now and
you know just trying to get as intense
and and personal with them as possible
is really just like i don't know
sometimes i wonder if there's anything
that's going to really give me that
sense of fulfillment yeah but you
mentioned a dollar amount maybe that's
like if i had this you know i wouldn't
could you throw out a dollar amount that
that kind of you had in your mind or
like like a goal or like if i hit x
amounts well there's a a lyric from the
great little baby where he says
i ain't got a hundred million i can't
chill yet
i felt that
so 100 mil well i just thought you know
at 100 mil maybe i could chill but
definitely i can't chill before that
it's a good goal i like that wow
well that's a number i couldn't imagine
what the [ __ ] i would do with it so at
least that's you know
it would be a new world of problems
perhaps but you said you don't spend
your money on much like do you not have
expensive taste or anything nothing no
cars
i don't know what do you drive at least
an i8 or something some bmw i don't know
i don't even know anything more the i8s
with the doors that go on yeah but that
can cause the doors don't go up oh then
um i i don't know because oh it's
probably my girl's dad got mad at me
because he said he said like what kind
of car you're getting i said that bmw
because what kind of
i don't know much about cars i don't
know anything about sports i have many
many cultural blind spots sure yeah
clothes
nothing fancy dinners
we'll go out for nice dinners maybe it's
still like relative to your income
that's 500 bucks every couple weeks or
something you know me and my girls are
very into exercising
um
diet and stuff too so that would
probably keep me from getting too into
fine dining wow
that's incredible you could only spend
money on a nicer house
yeah you know that's always something
for me but the thing about it is is that
when we really like now that we've owned
a house
and it's
three and a half million or something
four million it's like the realization
that the the house that we want
or that would actually
be good for us in the long run is
probably more like ten yeah that's kind
of like oh [ __ ] that's a lot of money
that's a big
that's a lot to bite off there i also
really want to have a skate park and
like a warehouse
um ideally like near my current spot i
would love to just have it buy a
warehouse and like buy around like
calabasas area
yeah a little further inland though but
if i got to drive 40 minutes north i
don't know if that's going to suck the
fun out of it but i would love to have
that glendale
glendale yeah that's where my girl's
from yep
now is there anything else any any
questions for us that you could think of
[ __ ] let's go get some steak all right
that sounds delicious thank you so much
this is actually my boy landon yeah yeah
thank you landon yeah his camera turned
off at some point but yeah i heard the
click but we never ended up using it so
you know what we yeah it doesn't even
work anyway well thank you guys we're
really appreciative of this man no doubt
appreciate you guys thank you really
appreciate it did you get your free
stock down below in the description when
you sign up for public certainly not no
graham no you didn't get a jack i
haven't even gotten it no
i'm going to make you do it right
afterwards it's free all right thank you
all right thanks for subscribing thank
you so much we'll link to your info down
below in the description and until next
time appreciate you guys thank you man
that's actually that was great